hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to today's
film is um interesting and when I say
interesting I mean it has a very
interesting history the name of the film
is the thief in the copy
or the princess in the copy
or maybe a night
or an abomination of a sness which is
what most people if a film can't decide
on what the title is how can't decide on
the audience it's going to appeal to is
it appealing to toddlers to older
children to the mainstream Disney crowd
the strange surreal fantasy crowd what
what well before I talk about the bill
let's talk about the film once upon a
time there's an animator named Richard
Williams he said to be one of the great
animation directors having done the
Chuck Jones produced Christmas Carol
that trippy Raggedy Ann and Andy Phil
and probably his biggest accomplishment
the animation for Who Framed Roger
Rabbit yet before all of that he started
production on the thief and the cobbler
in 1964 it was released in 1993 but the
hell happened all that time apparently
the film was independently funded and
Williams went on and on saying that this
was gonna be his masterpiece because of
this the film took years and years of
perfecting and financing to finally get
it finished in fact one of the actors
died before the film even got released
Vincent Price recorded his dialogue over
20 years before I ever saw the light of
day and as of now it continues to be the
longest time it's ever taken to complete
an animated picture because this turkey
was taken so long the film was bought by
the completion bond company and kicked
Williams off the project having it
released by Miramax and putting together
their own half-assed cut that is still
considered to be the cum bucket of a
dead cock this is that version so let's
see how this magnum opus went to magnum
anus in the thief and the cobbler we
start out appropriately enough with a
little backstory legend has it that each
shooting star is really an Arabian
Knight riding across the heavens oh god
don't tell me that's a lot of fish
that's right
Matthew Broderick is the star of this
movie must have been one of the
wonderful choices the bond company made
seeing how he was probably a spurned by
the time this movie began production
long before the heroic tales of Aladdin
and Alibaba
the first Arabian night was chosen you
hear that Disney we sort of beat you to
it the golden city of Baghdad high atop
its tallest tower were three golden
balls
he's magic protected it from the evil
king one eye his army of darkness
according to the prophecy if the balls
were ever removed Baghdad would be in
great danger no Kevin so we finally see
our heroes simply known as tech a pretty
pale looking fellow for someone who
lives in the desert at the time I was a
poor orphan working as a cobbler's
apprentice life was simple and an answer
to your question no I don't know why he
looks like Betelgeuse is right to the
end all but he's not the only main
character we also had the thief played
by Jonathan winters he never talks in
the movie yeah but sadly someone decided
to put a microphone in his brain
Lana Dunham nobody lives like this
except village kids at first this isn't
too bad but trust me it gets real
Annoying real fast so while he tries to
steal from the cobbler the Yellow
Submarine Pride Parade is happening
outside welcoming the arrival of the
Wizards zig zag played by Vincent Price
[Music]
so tech is captured as we cut through
our love interest in the movie princess
yum-yum okay hold on
tack zigzag yum-yum these aren't names
he said words an infant is trying to say
for the first time okay so the princess
has a real original backstory and you're
ready for this I bet you've never heard
this one before listen she's tired of
her pouring wine and in a bizarre twist
she dreams of wanting more I know I
could do more if I just had the chance
this life I live in regal splendor seems
a waste
I do hope there's a tired unoriginal
musical number to tell us what we
already know she feels one just to
delight right human bred to be
but
is more than
there's a mind in the body of this
pretty
by God is this song planned I mean this
is like eating styrofoam on wheat toast
it's that bland
it's like someone approached somebody
like Alan Menken and said hey can you
write an original song sure what's it
about it's about a princess who's
dreaming of more alright that's good oh
and just like those other Disney songs
where the landscapes and grand visuals
are stunning this musical performance
has spinning and spinning and
[Music]
motherfucking spinning god it's like we
got the choreography from the Tasmania
Ballet Theatre
so Tek is brought to the king of zigzags
prisoner when Yong Yong meets him for
the first time
[Music]
hmm
but the princess informs her father that
she needs a cobbler so he's called in to
fix her shoe meanwhile we discovered
that zig zag has an evil plan - you
guessed it take over the golf course
sport with Princess yum-yum at my side
the crown is mine oh by the way did I
mention that he speaks entirely in rhyme
greatest king of all the earth
this lowborn cobbler of no wealth
attacked me in the square today shall we
take his head away I'm not even sure I
really get it why does he speak in rhyme
if everybody else doesn't is there a
reason for it I mean what makes him so
special I hello the Vincent Price like
the Vincent Price wait a minute you've
been dead for years
wait so everything you're saying right
now is a recording how is that possible
how do you know everything I'm not that
- stop Peter Piper she says all right
recording of Vincent Price what do you
want
strikes me with humiliation in
discomfort you see I want you to know
why I stammered in rhythmic drawers of
iambic pentameter in this cinematic
adventure you mean explain why you mind
okay well why that's just great years
after your death and you can't remember
why you rhymed in that movie what what
pumpkin what so we see the cobbler
interact with the princess as he fixes
her shoe
the princess was so beautiful and I was
just an ordinary cobbler doesn't have a
lot to say for himself
oh don't worry he's in her mind along
good never shuts the fuck up we'll make
up for that I tried to impress her with
some cobbling tricks why can't I ever
talk when it matters you can say that
for all the lines in this movie speaking
of which the other inner monologue
Rambler comes in looking for something
to steal so oh so that's what it looks
like I've heard evidence storybooks and
songs
what's Oh naked lady oh but wait a
golden scratcher
but record scratches but what's better
but great dad so he steals the scratchy
rosin to the color who tries to stop it
halt in the name of King nod I couldn't
believe what I was saying suddenly I was
defending the crown and I have to admit
this is one of the coolest yet still
trim pious chase scenes you ever see in
an animated film
[Music]
[Applause]
so after that trip house zig-zag sees
that text finish the shoe when so he
puts him in a cell I was sure I would
never see the princess again little did
I know that she was thinking about me
too oh yeah
another underwritten song to rape us
with its blandness
[Music]
yeah you thought the first song was bad
just listen to the lyrics on this one
don't fight your feelings says my heart
a heart I will obey
Wow that's the kind of laziness that you
only dream about you know because you're
so fucking lazy I mean it's like if
Homer Simpson Garfield Snoopy and Al
Bundy all procrastinate until the last
minute and finally came up with these
lyrics I mean even trying
anyone can come up with this shit my
heart will love her love love love but
only in my tree
but because I think with thenis the
dreams I dream I'll dream
by heart alone
[Music]
so we cut to the next day Azteca still
locked away in his cell I had to escape
oh god shut up this evil has more in her
bottle oven samus from Metroid Other M
zigzag had ordered a polo match in
yum-yum's honor of course she was far
from impressed if only Adam was here to
tell me what to think so the next day
tech breaks free out of his cell as the
thief tries to steal the golden balls
from the top of the castle finally I was
free the grass felt soft on my feet why
don't I monologue about that for several
hours the grass is green a frog is green
I'm sure I can talk about this in great
detail somehow eventually the thief
manages to get the golden balls as he
hears a shocker monologues to itself
you're gonna hear Disney life you know
it's funny when I hear pop cultural
references in a film that takes place in
Arabia I think of Aladdin but this was
being made before Aladdin apparently
Disney animators drew influence from
this movie why was being made that
helped Aladdin get off the ground and
after that came out the new producers of
this film
drew inflows from Aladdin so Aladdin
ripped off this only to have this ripoff
Aladdin basically the film is a product
of animated inbreeding
suddenly this is all starting to make
more sense isn't it so a soldier comes
and tells the king that an evil army is
brewing led by an evil man named woe
[Music]
Fuhrer pocketing people so as the King
prepares his army zigzag manages to get
the golden Spears from the thief I have
the balls and AD everybody
I will zigzag decides to give the balls
to one eye while the princess has an
idea about how to solve the problem
apparently there's a witch in the desert
that's all knowledgeable but who's gonna
go talk to earth where do I find this
witch you never much too dangerous
father I'm smarter than any man in this
city and faster than your clumsy
henchmen as was proven by the previous
scenes of her running fast and being
smart okay bitch all you did was sing it
spit I don't know how that qualifies you
to be a speed against time that's
current so she chooses the cobbler to be
his guy because he's lived all his life
in the village and has no idea how the
desert works oh I mean uh has great
knowledge of the desert and all its
secrets you can tell how many times he's
been out there by the incredibly dark
ten that he has all over his body
clearly he is no stranger to the Sun
okay so they set out into the desert
under the cover of royal escort to find
the sudden plot device known as the
winch
he was looking like Jeff Burton's Prince
of Persia now he has a tail like George
Hamilton I know what you're thinking is
cuz he went out in the Sun that he
suddenly tan but look as they're leaving
his skin is a different color and it's
nighttime this doesn't add up what did
the animators suffer a fatal heart
attack and then somebody else took over
and forgot to tell the tech is pale
continuity it's not just about coherent
anymore so they run into a bunch of
desert outlaws called the brigands they
sing another song that makes you want to
scalp yourself and then they decide to
join them in their search for the winch
at last we reached the hands of glory
all we had to do was wait into the next
day when the Sun would be directly
overhead and the magic moment would
arrive or maybe the writers could have
just had us arrive on time but we found
this wasted more animation and let's
face it we're on a roll with that so
they see the witch who has some
confusing yet somehow still generic
advice to give our heroes I also have
some battle strategies over there but
then I find shooting out windows it's a
lot more fun so we see zigzag and the
balls over to one eye and they prepare
to take over the city you know what
never even told what kind of power the
balls have or even what they do we never
see them in motion and we don't really
know how powerful they are are we just
supposed to assume there
so one eyes army attacks with whatever
the hell this thing is
as six egg tries to take out tank attack
attack attack
[Music]
well I guess when you make a machine
that implausible you're just begging for
it to be taken down in an implausible
wet but there's still the final battle
fee hair with zig zagging tech that was
easy you're buying tricks what I don't
think he said anything so tech defeats
the wizard by sewing him up the thief
gets the golden balls back and One
Nights army is destroyed and in the end
we find that non-threatening blandest
wins the day
so next time you see a shooting star be
proud of who you really are do in your
heart what you know is right and you too
shall become an Arabian night last year
an animator who spends most of its life
and thousands of dollars tried to tell
the story he's always wanted to tell in
which case you're totally screw
Claire and so I have good news and bad
news the bad news is there's movie size
it's edited clumsily the songs are
forgettable the characters are
annoyingly bland as well as annoying
it's just a horrible release however the
good news is there is a reentered of
this movie called the recalled cunt
this uses unfinished animation and
storyboards to tell the version that
Richard Williams always wanted to see
and let me tell you it's a lot better
there's no Matthew project or Jonathan
winters no shitty ass songs and
virtually no dialogue from the main
characters which is actually pretty
unique because of this most of the
stories told strictly through the
animation which while some people may
see as an acquired taste is still pretty
spectacular there's so much more
expression in just the movements of the
character than there is with that
horrible inner monologue it knows what
it wants to be a surreal artistic
practically silent movie
unlike the mere maxcut which try so hard
to appeal to everyone that it appeals to
no one and while I can't say theory
cobble cut is a fantastic movie it's
certainly more impressive and much more
entertaining it's worth checking out for
any fan of animation if you just type in
thief and the cobbler recalled cut on
Google or YouTube you'll come across it
eventually check it out and see some
really great animation
[Music]
[Applause]
now that I have the balls